this evening we actually have a pretty
stable set of instruments what we're
working with the collection as I said of
a lot you know we have about 6,000
orchestrations the the music was
arranged so that it could be used by a
variable sized orchestra because they
didn't know who was going to be
performing it all depended on the budget
of the theater and in small theater you
might just have a piano or a piano
violin and drums piano violin and cello
or you might have a 30 40-piece
Orchestra some of the larger halls and
they all worked from the same
orchestrations they were carefully
arranged and cross cued so that if you
didn't have an oboe the clarinet player
knows to play the oboe cues if you do
have an oboe the clarinet doesn't play
them and they would have to do they get
used to how to play these things and
we've gotten used to a five-piece group
the piano is there because it's a small
group the piano is basically filling in
for all the instruments that are missing
the violin is playing the lead lines
most of the time
the clarinet plays a lot of harmonies
and whenever you get an exotic thing
with beau geste we've got a couple of
sort of what you might call oriental
cues where you want that sort of
otherworldly nasal sound that you get in
Arabian music and the clarinet comes to
the fore there the trumpet is useful for
adding power to the melody lines when
it's when things get loud and especially
in the battle sequences Beau Geste ends
with three rather apocalyptic battles
you see as you said these thousands of
Arabs coming over the dunes and we've
got a small number of people in the fort
trying to stay alive and we want to
emphasize that so big noise lots of
chaos and the music when the cello is
the fifth instrument and that again is
used to do a lot of filling out the
baseline but also a lot of counter
melody writing in the base the cello is
very different from what the base would
be doing then the instruments that we're
missing the second violins a viola is
the basis and the the flute and the
percussion most of that's covered by me
on the piano just filling out the
background and making the things sound
bigger
you
you